my name is s Amla fan I'm the former
minister for petroleum and natural
resources coming to Pakistan and also
for my ambassador to the United Arab
Emirates and special envoy to the Middle
East Government of Pakistan I'm here as
a senior adviser to crescent petroleum
I'm here because I'm extremely concerned
and that where is the Arab Spring has
taken place we are now looking at a
winter of discontent and possibly a bit
of inter in case we do not appreciate
that the base is one of the key races
for the Arab springs was unemployment
and of course national dignity and lack
of education be in the Muslim world and
in particular in the Arab world have to
move quickly to eliminate these
shortcomings and job creation and
cutting down unemployment levels is of
paramount importance only when a man is
hungry he comes out on the streets when
his family has looked after when his
stomach is full is quite happily sitting
at home